[DIGITAL TONES]
VALLI BINDANA: So let's
start with a very tiny story.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- And so she came down to
earth with such a force
that everyone was scared that
the Earth will split into two.
That's when Shiva
stepped forward and said,
leave this to me!
Let her fall on my head.
I will slow her down
with my long matted hair.
- He had a moon on his head?
- Yeah, and he even looks
like the Himalayan mountains.
The moon is white like
the snow-capped peaks.
The River Ganga flows
from all that snow
and ice melt, the glaciers.
And all that here are the
dense forests and vegetation.
- And this snake?
Is that about wild
animals in the forests?
What do you think, Mama?
[END PLAYBACK]
So in 2013, when I
began making this film,
I was not a researcher.
I was not a scientist.
I was not religious.
I'm not now.
I was not a social worker,
not an engineer, not a tribal.
I was not a fish.
I was just a common human
in search of a river--
my river.
This is the Ganga,
known as Ganges
in the rest of the world.
We used to holiday
by this river.
This was sometime back, about
15 years back, with my family--
with my mum and my
brothers and my dad.
And we would go to this river
for a few days every year
for a few years.
And we would have a
really, really good time.
Very, very memorable moments
we would spend there.
And the river used to
flow at that time and flow
very swift and very fast.
And the color was as you
see here, very bluish-green.
And we were mesmerized
by this river.
So yeah, we fell in love.
And here's another shot.
This is the river
coming downhill
on the foothills of the
Himalayas in Rishikesh.
A lot of water--
there were no dams
upstream at that point.
And then I took a
break of a few years.
And I did not go.
And then life happened.
And I had a child.
And she grew up
to be 5-years-old.
And when she was five,
I thought it was time
for her to experience
Ganga and for her to go.
And it was time for me to
introduce her to the river
and have her see what I
had been talking about.
And I had been telling
her all these stories,
like the one you heard--
very dramatized versions of
mythology or even geography.
Not just mythology--
geography-- like,
the entire Indian
subcontinent-- how it came.
And it rammed into Asia.
And all these mountains
came up, and all of that.
She would be awed
by these stories.
And there were stories about
the fish-- the [INAUDIBLE] fish,
which was 3 feet, sometimes 4--
much bigger than her.
And I would tell her about
the family times we have had
and how I had spent time
with my mother by the river
and, now, she should
also see what it all
meant for all of us.
And she got pretty
excited about it.
And so we went back.
And we always used to
go into the Himalayas,
where the river was,
not in the plains.
So we went back there.
And this is what we
found off the river.
Now, this is the
Bhagirathi River.
Now, there are two main rivers,
Bhagirathi and Alaknanda, that
originate in the Himalayas.
And then they come down and meet
at a place called Devprayag.
And from there, it
starts becoming Ganga.
It's called Ganga, but
it's the same river.
So this is the Bhagirathi.
This is how it looked like.
And-- no river.
It's all gone.
It's not like we
misplace our keys
or we say, oh, our
wallet has disappeared.
Where is our wallet?
It's disappeared.
The entire river, or what we
saw it, was not there at all.
Some puddles of water here
and there-- very stagnant.
No sounds of gushing
water of course.
So we talked to
the local people.
And we asked, so what happened?
And they said, well, our
region has developed.
And a lot of
developmental activity
is taking place
around this place.
And there are a few dams
upstream that have come up,
which are generating
electricity for the country.
And so then we said, OK.
And my daughter again had-- of
course-- questions of her own.
And she asked, so where
did all the water go?
Which was a very
valid question--
where did all the water go?
And then she said, where
did all the fish go?
The water is there.
Where did the fish go?
And then she asked
me a question, which
sort of put me up a stump.
And she asked me, if the
river is not there, why do you
tell me stories about it?
Now, she was questioning
my storytelling.
So I didn't have any answers
at that point for her.
And my brother was there.
Marthand was there.
And we discussed about it.
And we wondered, why a river--
and this is not just a river.
This is the Ganges
we are talking about.
Ganges is-- we talk
about her since eternity.
It's in our mythology.
We say, she's responsible for
the birth of a civilization.
And we call her Mother
Goddess and all of that.
And yet, when a
river disappears,
there is no talk about
it down in the plains
where we came from.
And not just talk--
the media doesn't
discuss about it.
People like us,
common people who
just go about our daily lives--
we don't know that there is
no Ganges up in the mountains.
So nobody's talking about this.
So that was more disturbing,
that something like this
has happened, and nobody
is talking about it.
So we thought,
let's do something.
Right-- so what do we do?
Let's get people
to know about this.
How do we get people
to know about this?
If we go down and tell
them, there is no Ganges,
they'll say, what are
you talking about?
Ganga has been
there for so long.
So we said, OK, let's
make a film about it.
And I forget to tell you, 2013--
I was not a film-maker either.
And so Marthand knew
something about the cameras.
And so he bought a camera-- a
tiny little camera-- a Canon.
And I remember, we got a
very tiny audio equipment.
We got a $30 Lav mic.
And with very, very
basic equipment,
we set out to meet
people who have
been working in this area of
water and rivers for decades.
This is another
shot of AsiGanga,
which is another
tributary of the Ganga--
the Ganges-- up in the
mountains-- no water at all.
So we began our meeting--
a person called
Himanshu Thakkur.
He is a coordinator of
SANDRP, South Asian Network
of Dams, Rivers, and People.
And this organization-- and
Himanshu, in particular--
has been working on rivers--
and he's a researcher.
He's been working on river
issues for a long, long time.
And if there's any
person you need to have,
if you have any questions,
he's the person to go to.
Because he's like
an encyclopedia
of all of these issues.
So we met him.
And we had this tiny
set of equipment.
And we had loads and
loads of questions.
So we met him.
And this is one of the first
interviews that we did.
And I think we interviewed
about three or four times
over the period of four years.
So he introduced us to the
issue of how everything
came to being what it is.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[END PLAYBACK]
So just a little background on
where we were at that point,
at the time we started
making the film.
This was, again, 2013.
And all of these figures
are very suspect,
in the sense that all the people
that we talked to-- and this
includes the Ministry of Power.
They never came up with a single
figure or a very confident
answer to our questions.
So there were 51 operating
hydropower projects,
each over 1 megawatts.
[INAUDIBLE] were operational.
And this is all in
the Ganga River Basin.
And then 40 projects under
construction-- again,
a number which you can say,
give or take a few projects.
And then the last one
is quite a whopper.
It is 80 to 600.
So at that point,
the number of dams
being planned on the
Ganga River Basin
were anywhere between
80 to 600 dams.
And these are all
hydropower projects
on the Ganga River Basin.
So if all of these would come
to fruition, if all of these
were set up, the
Ganga River Basin
would become one of the densest
dam sites on the planet.
So now, each of
these projects need
to go through a certain
set of clearances.
And one of the clearances is
the environmental clearance.
And our focus was on
that, because that
is what we were dealing with--
the environment.
So here is Himanshu again.
Now, when he gave
the interview, he
talked to us about
environmental clearances
and all the processes
that need to be
or ideally should be followed.
For about 20 minutes
he talked about it.
So quite a complex process
and quite intricate--
and I have about two
minutes of it for you now.
And he talks about
hydropower projects.
But we can apply,
probably-- or nearly--
the same processes for other
forms of big centralized energy
production as well.
So let's hear what he has to
say about environmental impact
assessment, which
is a EIA process.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[END PLAYBACK]
So he talks about
a couple of things.
He talks about the
cut-and-paste jobs of the EIAs.
And this has happened
earlier in some assessments.
There have been names
of animals and shrubs
and foliage and trees reported
in the assessment, which don't
exist in the region at all.
That is how shoddy the
environment reports are.
And he talks about cumulative
impact assessments.
Now, this is also a
very important point.
And he really, really elaborated
on it when we talked about it.
So cumulative
means what it says.
It means that when a project
comes up on a river there are
a whole lot of other activities
that surround the project--
for example--
now again, going back to the
two rivers, the Bhagirathi
and the Alaknanda,
there are a whole lot
of tributaries that come
and join into these two
big major rivers.
Now dams are proposed
and dams are planned
and dams are being constructed
in all of these tributaries.
And these are pristine areas.
These are untouched
Himalayan regions,
where there is no road,
there is no electricity,
there is hardly anything there
except a few villages here
and there scattered.
So when a project comes
up there, how do you get--
what you need is people.
You need big heavy equipment
to be transported there.
So how do you do that?
You build roads.
And how do you build roads?
And we're not talking
about flat surfaces.
We're talking about 45-degree
angles and mountains
that are steep.
And how do you do that?
You blast your way through
into these regions.
Now, Himalayas are a very
young mountain range.
And they are very
brittle in nature.
And when you actually
go into the mountains
and you scrape the mountainsides
that have been cut,
you will find just pebbles
and rocks and mud and sand.
They are not like solid
rock that will stay.
When they blast their
way through the mountains
and into these pristine areas,
the mountains move about.
They tremble.
They vibrate.
And so that results in a
whole lot of landslides.
Now, when we were driving
up and down the Basin,
there were times
when we wouldn't see
the road for a long, long time.
Why?
Because there had
been landslides
throughout the entire
road that we were very,
very slowly going.
And this is in the case
throughout the Basin.
And then there are these
run-of-the-river tunnels.
So there are many
different types of dams.
There are gravity dams.
And then there are these
run-of-the-river dams,
which are showcased by the
companies and the governments
as the most
environmentally-friendly
technologies.
Which sound very good actually,
the way they describe it.
But the way they are
implemented in the mountains
is very different.
So what they do is
they put a wall--
put a [INAUDIBLE] in place.
They stop the water.
The water level rises.
And then they dig a
tunnel through from here.
And then they keep
digging a tunnel inside.
And the tunnel takes
the entire water
from the river--
from the storage.
And it goes.
And the dam that we were--
[INAUDIBLE] Dam-- the tunnel
was about 8.2 kilometers long.
So that now, the river
water is in the tunnels.
And outside, the river
bed was completely dry.
And then downstream somewhere,
they would release the water.
The turbines would spin.
The electricity would be made.
Now, you would say, OK.
There are hundreds of kilometers
of river lengths in the Basin.
What would this do?
8 kilometers is not a big deal.
But the way it is implemented
is the dam wall is here.
The river is dry.
The water is released here.
And the next dam begins
right in front of it.
So now, we're talking
about a cascade of dams
throughout the Basin.
Now, the way they
dig the tunnels
is again with blasting of
dynamite and other explosives.
So all of this results in a lot
of shaking and a lot of damage
in this very, very
fragile mountain
range and a lot of landslides
and land sinking happens.
And sometimes it results
in a very serious damage
to the villages that are
there in the mountains.
Let's hear this out.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- One such village that
had faced the brunt
is Jhamak perched right
above the tunnel entrance
of one of Himalayan dams.
- It was '91 or '92.
There was a single
earthquake in Uttarkashi.
And around that time, all
the other villages-- there
was not so much destruction.
But Jhamak [INAUDIBLE]----
there were maximum number
of casualties.
Why there were maximum
number of casualties?
This is the area where,
apart from the tunnel,
there was nothing else.
- 76 people died
in Jhamak alone.
The incident wasn't isolated.
Throughout the
Ganga River Basin,
around construction sites of
these massive developmental
projects, as the
earth below trembles--
[END PLAYBACK]
So this was just one of
the many, many incidents
that happened in the Himalayas.
This is a 2018 news item--
very recent.
And it talks about
mountain springs drying up.
This is being reported
in the mainstream media.
And it is 2018.
But actually, this news
is not news of 2018.
This has been happening
for many, many years.
And when we went, we
saw firsthand just how
this impacted the local people.
We have Mallica and Bharat
Dehi and [INAUDIBLE]
talk about this.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- [SPEAKING HINDI]
These are fresh water sources.
And they have been [INAUDIBLE]
water sources for villages
since eternity.
Now when blasting starts to
happen and then these boulders,
these mountains,
they move about,
the water gets displaced.
All the fresh water
of the mountains,
it just flows into the tunnels.
So obviously, there is
nothing in the villages.
- [SPEAKING HINDI]
- Because we are here in
[INAUDIBLE] and we work
continuously in the communities,
two years ago when we had
a very severe drought, we did
a deep survey of, what was it
doing to women and children?
75% of the streams
had disappeared
because of climate havoc--
because climate
change intensifies
drought and floods and cyclones.
Women were having to walk
even further for water.
Worse, children had
stopped going to school,
because they had to carry
that additional pot.
When a stream comes through, you
fill your pit in five minutes
and go home.
When it comes as a trickle,
drop by drop by drop,
a child is standing
there for six hours
to collect one
day's need of water.
Women and children always
carry the heaviest burden
of ecological destruction.
And the disappearance of
water is no exception.
[END PLAYBACK]
So we actually followed a
couple of-- not these women.
But we actually followed
a couple of women
when they walked about
a kilometer, a kilometer
and a 1/2, to collect
water for their house--
just simple household needs.
And we took the camera.
And we actually followed.
And this was, again,
in the Himalayas.
So 1 and 1/2 kilometers
of walking for them
is OK, because they've always
walked 1 and 1/2 kilometers up
in the mountains.
But for us, with all the
equipment and everything,
it was pretty tedious.
So there's a very
interesting story about how--
the first day we went
into the village.
And we were carrying
again our equipment.
And we were city folk--
very unfit people.
So we went there.
And we go into the house.
And guess what the first
thing that they ask us is?
They ask us, would you have
like to have a glass of water?
And so I said, yeah, sure.
And this is the first day
of shoot in the village.
And they bring water.
And I drink it up.
And then the whole
day, we shoot.
And we go back.
And then, when we
shoot, actually then
we find out just how the
water came into their house.
And so the next day,
we went back again.
And they asked, water?
I said, oh, no, no, no.
We're fine.
We're good.
And if you go back--
and we shoot the whole day.
And you're thirsty like crazy.
And we go back to the place
where we were staying.
And the caretaker comes.
And I said, oh, I want water.
I'm really, really thirsty.
They said, what happened?
I said, I didn't drink there.
So he started laughing.
He just doubled up.
So in a way, it is normal for
them to accept these hardships
and still go on with life.
And these two women actually--
what they are holding
on their backs
is food and foliage
for their cows.
Now, each family that--
the village we went
to, [INAUDIBLE]----
each family had about one
or two cows or a calf.
Earlier, what they
tell me, is they used
to have four or five or more.
But now, they cannot
maintain so many,
because they have to feed and
actually take care of them.
So the way their economics
works is, in their household,
there's a cow.
And the cow gives plenty.
And the cows give milk also.
So the women, they feed the cow.
And they milk.
And they sell the milk
and get the money.
So now, if you don't
feed the cow properly,
they don't give enough milk.
So now, when the springs
and the groundwater
was there, say,
about 20 years back,
the women would go out
at 6:00 in the morning
and collect this water and
come back by 10:00 or 11:00
during the day.
And then they have farming
to do, kids to take care of,
and all the other
stuff going on.
But now, since the
springs are gone
and the groundwater is
gone, the forests are dry--
and they call it
[HINDI] is grass.
It's not grass.
It's foliage.
But anyways, the
cattle don't graze.
So the women have to go
deep into the mountains--
and what they told me was
about 20 to 25 kilometers--
every single day to get
a bunch of this kind
of foliage for the cows to eat.
So they would leave at
6:00 in the morning.
And they would come back
at around 4:00 or 5:00
in the evening, just for
one job of feeding the cows.
So you would
understand what happens
to the rest of the
work that is there--
the farms to be
tilled and other work
that is there in the house.
That doesn't get done.
This was a gruesome one.
So a river, the
geography of it--
the river acts as a
barrier against predators
and natural hazards from other
parts of the whole region.
So if there's a village here and
there's a river flowing there,
the village stays
protected from elements
from the other
side of the river.
When the river goes--
oh, there's another
part to this.
When the river goes, the
leopards come, that's fine.
So over centuries,
the way the people die
is they would
cremate their dead.
So they would cremate their
dead beside the river Ganges.
Now, sometimes it so happens
that the wood is damp.
And so it's not burned properly,
the corpse is still there.
So in such cases, when
the leopards come,
they get a taste of human flesh.
And they turn man-eaters.
Now, this is not folklore.
We were there.
And we saw them living this.
We saw corpses being burned.
The fear of leopards around was
so near and so discomforting.
Nobody would go out alone
at dusk or beyond that.
They would carry stuff.
They would carry sticks
and some kind of thing
to ward the attack off.
But this danger was there, very,
very present in the region.
It's not just one village
we're talking about.
We're talking about [INAUDIBLE],,
which is a small town beside
the village--
but very real and
very, very present.
So Bijna Devi is a village
elder from [INAUDIBLE] who talks
about it--
very matter-of-factly,
by the way.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[SPEAKING HINDI]
[END PLAYBACK]
So I bet none of
these stories would
have even featured in any of the
EIAs that we are talking about.
So all that I showed you
today or talked about
is not there in the film.
The film-- giving you
a very raw deal here.
And I talked about just
the hydro component of it.
And hydro is just
1/3 of the film.
There's coal.
And then there's the
rise of solar and wind.
And we go in depth
into each area,
talking to-- again--
researchers, doctors,
and social workers, and people,
and the builders themselves.
So what's there in the film?
In the film, we have--
these are very few of the
things that are listed here.
But there's more.
There's social and
cultural impact
of a disappearing Ganges.
There's geology and seismicity.
And these dams are built on top
of faults and some very active
faults as well.
Farming and livelihood
is something
that we covered a little bit.
Fish-- we covered--
again, it's a panoptic film.
We are connecting the
dots between a whole lot
of different perspectives.
We set out to find the
truth about what's going on.
But all we found
were perspectives.
A scientist would have
a different perspective.
A villager would have a
different-- the same valley,
the same river, the
same water-- we're
talking about the same issue.
There are so many
different perspectives.
And this fish is
also a perspective.
So we covered that as well.
And we covered a little bit of
Northeastern Himalaya as well.
The same sort of issues
are taking place, if not
more dramatic.
Because the Brahmaputra
is a big volume river.
And then there's the
dark side of coal, which
is the second 1/3 of the film.
And then there's rise
of solar and wind.
So I'll move on to--
oh, the making of "SunGanges."
So when I finished
the film-- and this
is an independent
production completely.
When I finished the film,
my peers and people said,
it's a big deal.
And I didn't know
about it actually.
So it's hard to just list
out, on hindsight, what we did
to finish this entire feature.
We did not know the story
when we began filming.
We had these questions.
But the answers
would make the story
that the film would be about.
We didn't know the answers.
So there was a downside to
it, that a lot of wastage
happened-- that we covered
a whole lot of things
about hundreds of
hours of footage
and that had to be
condensed into, say, an hour
and 1/2 or less.
And it was like taming a
wild beast on the edit table.
So in case any of you are
thinking of making a film,
knowing your story would
be a good way to start.
Not knowing is also
good, because then you
approach the project with
a really, really open mind.
We listened a lot.
We listened to everybody.
We listened to the
children in the village.
We listened to the tribals.
We listened to the researchers.
We listened to the boy who
served us in the restaurant.
We listened to everybody.
And that really, really helped
get more and more perspective
into the film.
We did not wait for
stuff to happen.
We did not wait for the grants.
We did not wait
for emails-- people
to get back with their emails.
We did not wait for anything.
We just plunged into the
deep end with the camera
and whatever little that we had.
We made full use of our
ignorance about the subject,
about what's going on.
And that is probably because
of why the film turned out
to be the way it is right now.
And we stayed
stubborn throughout.
It took about 4 and
1/2 years to make.
And it got ready
of late last year.
And it made a European premiere
in Germany early this year.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
[END PLAYBACK]
MODERATOR: If you
have any questions,
there's a mic right there.
AUDIENCE: So it sounds like
what you're proposing--
what the movie's proposing-- is
a push for renewable energy--
mainly solar and
wind, I'm guessing.
VALLI BINDANA: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Does India have
that natural capacity
to sustain itself with those
kind of renewable energies?
Because one of the
arguments I hear
is that hydro-power is
important because it is such
a easy and powerful
renewable energy source.
And so people are
reluctant to say--
even in the US, they're like,
we can't just not build dams.
But it seems like there are
natural consequences to that.
VALLI BINDANA: Yeah, so there
are natural consequences.
You would see it in the film.
Arguments are put forth
in favor of big hydro.
And the arguments are
that it's clean and green.
And I would echo all the
researchers that we talked to.
And they would say
that, well, it depends
upon how you define clean.
And how you do define green.
If you're submerging
a whole lot of land
and if you're drying
up rivers, then how
would you define it as green?
Especially when there
is an alternative energy
source available,
which is getting
cheaper and cheaper by the day.
Again, there are
arguments in favor of coal
as well, despite
all that we show
in the film and all that
is-- and again, the film
covers a lot.
But then please be
mindful that it's just
the tip of the iceberg
of what actually
is happening all over the
country and all over the world
probably.
So there are
arguments put forth.
But when you compare
just what a dam does
to a river and the ecosystem and
what a distributed solar model
does, there is no
comparison, when
it comes to
destroying livelihoods
and cultures and just the
ecology of the entire region.
AUDIENCE: OK, thanks
for making this.
And thanks for
presenting this today.
I have two questions.
One-- it seems like
the EIAs were actually
supposed to be an
actual mechanism
to protect against
bad decisions.
And they're failing incredibly.
And so the first question is,
did you see any optimistic sign
for the mechanism being
actually enforced?
Is there any hope that
the EIA will improve?
That the people responsible
will be held accountable?
And second question--
in your journeys,
did you come across
some examples where
the local community
was able to push back
against the [INAUDIBLE]
more hydro-power?
Were there any small local
victories against a larger--
top-down?
VALLI BINDANA: So actually,
I have-- do we have time?
I have about six
minutes of actual film
that I would like
to show to you.
It's about a time where
the entire discourse
about hydro-power dams in India
changed after that event--
the Uttarakhand floods.
AUDIENCE: OK.
VALLI BINDANA: So
it's part of the film.
And I'd like to show it to
you if we have time, right?
SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE]
five more minutes.
VALLI BINDANA: So
this was, again, 2013.
Just a little bit
of background--
and this part is towards
the end of the hydro segment
in the film.
It's about these
flash floods that
had happened in Uttarakhand
and what it did to the dams
and what the dams did to
the floods and the people.
So it was a very give-and-take
kind of situation there.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[BIRDS CHIRPING]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[CRASHING WATER]
[SPEAKING HINDI]
[LOUD WHISTLE]
[DRUMMING]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
Pancheshwar dam, which
is coming up with Nepal--
its about 311 meters
high-- it's going to be.
It has been cleared.
And it is in a high seismic zone
where earthquakes have happened
in the past few years, about
five or six times, all over 5
on the Richter scale.
So we did not cover
corruption in the film at all.
We just focused on the
technology and the economics
aspect of it and, of course,
the impacts and reactions
of other people and
their perspectives.
So corruption is
a different story.
Corruption is a series.
It can't be limited to a film.
It has to be a web
series or something.
It's too much.
It's too ingrained.
And if we expect them to do
a very good job of an EIA,
I think we are living
in a fool's paradise.
I don't think it's possible.
AUDIENCE: Can you talk about
the SunGanga [INAUDIBLE] and--
VALLI BINDANA: You've
got to watch the film.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
VALLI BINDANA: You've got
to watch the film for that.
AUDIENCE: I will watch it.
VALLI BINDANA: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: But you [INAUDIBLE]?
VALLI BINDANA: So when we
started making this film,
we started with just the river.
And then there was this very
famous author called Tony Seba.
I'm not sure if you
have heard of him yet.
But he wrote this book
called "Clean Disruption
of Energy and Transportation."
And we connected with him.
And he said, why are you just
limiting yourself to hydro?
There's coal.
There's this.
And then he opened
the can of worms.
And we got sucked into it.
And we expanded the entire film
to include the rise of solar
and wind as well.
The difference between filming
coal and hydro and solar
and wind was very,
very, very stark.
While hydro and coal-- it
was very difficult to film,
in the sense that there was
a lot to hide and people
were suspicious about
our making the film
or just having the camera.
The solar and wind guys
and all the companies,
they would really welcome us and
say, this is what we're doing.
And this is where we are
going to take this company.
Or these are our projects.
This is a product--
and all of that.
So it was very, very
different filming
the solar and wind
component of the film.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
SPEAKER: Thank you.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]